more on the news of a potential covid19
vaccine this morning joined now by the
chair
of the uk vaccine task force kate
bingham hello james bingham thanks very
much
for joining us on the program this
morning this sounds exciting
it is really cool good tell me more
about it
you know it all sounds like good news we
have to
temper our enthusiasm or should we just
all get the streamers out
now we have to be very cautious because
there has never been a vaccine against
a coronavirus and there may never be one
what we have been tasked to do is to
protect the uk population
uh against coven 19 through vaccination
and do so as quickly
as we can and the announcements this
morning show that the uk is absolutely
at the forefront of global efforts
to source and develop vaccines from
across the world
across a range of different technologies
scary isn't it when you hear there might
never be
a vaccine against it i don't think
there's one against sars is there
no and there's no vaccine against
malaria against hiv and these are
diseases we know well
so there is no expectation that this
definitely can be done
but the early data that we're seeing is
definitely encouraging
more trials in the works as well as
there's not just the one are they
working collaboratively together
yes so there's 23 uh vaccines in
clinical trials around the world
there has been enormous collaboration
and cooperation
both from academia from industry from
governments
it's incredibly impressive and people
have been working
at unprecedented speed so it is an
exciting
time and if you think about it the virus
was only identified at the beginning of
the year
and we've now got 23 vaccines in trials
oxford has vaccinated over 9 000 people
with their with their vaccine so this is
really quite remarkable
are we obliged obligated i should say to
uh share our information to share our
potential vaccines around the world
one of the goals of the vaccine task
force is both
to find vaccines for the uk but also to
ensure that any successful vaccine
is distributed um across the globe
so that anybody who is at risk of
covered infection
is vaccinated so we are not pursuing a
strategy of vaccine nationalism
we are recognizing that this is a global
pandemic and we need to ensure
that the globe and all those who need it
are vaccinated
okay so it's a breakthrough today what
happens next
the trials continue so what we have
announced today is that we've
secured rights to two new vaccines in
addition to the vaccines
being developed by oxford university and
imperial
and those vaccines will continue to
progress through clinical
trials they have to show that they are
both safe and they have to show that
they are protective
either that they can reduce mortality or
ideally and ultimately we want to show
that they can protect people
from even getting infected in the first
place and those trials basically will
continue
until we have a result how worried are
you about
um espionage people um trying to hack
the systems to steal the work that
you've done
and we've had uh continuous
uh support from the cyber security uh
teams
that uh we have not been hacked and
we're very alert to the fact that
this is potentially happening um but
it's
i'm not concerned that uh this is going
to disrupt in any way what we're doing
has it been i mean we've heard a lot
about russia trying to access
uh what we what our brilliant scientists
are doing are you
have you you've obviously made aware of
that have you actually seen it firsthand
as it were
i haven't seen the hacking i've had lots
of conversations with the cyber security
teams yes
okay um as you said next steps mean that
it's not yet a vaccine but you are going
to take it further to see
whether or not we could go for herd
immunity in the fullness of time with
with this vaccine
but i was reading an article this
morning
that suggested kate that 25 of the
population would not be interested
in having a vaccine that's presumably
because they're anxious about
potentially being given covet 19 or
whatever they're interpreting it as what
would you
say to reassure my viewers this morning
so all i would suggest to the viewers
sitting
at their coffee tables uh having having
breakfast
is we are incredibly fortunate to be
living in a world
uh in which diseases not that long ago
were killing millions of children so if
you think about
smallpox that has now been eradicated
polio
and so on if we can find vaccines that
are safe and effective
the restrictions that we are currently
facing will stop
we will return to normal vaccination has
been a huge benefit to society
and should continue to do so